folks this just in over the wire we got
a hot new merch drop get back drop baby
from november 8th to november 18th you
can get your limited edition toddy's
goodies we're asking everyone to remain
calm
we're gonna have a real black friday
situation on our hands we got bernie's
teas and hoodies we got hoodies tees we
got hoodies tees and hoodies we got
bunkos we got bonkos tees and hoodies
guys uh the link will be in the
description go to bonfire.com
are you garbage limited edition only
available for 10 or 11 days get them
while they're available get the holiday
orders in now welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage sure is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that if they grow
up to be classy or if they're just a big
old piece of trash you got it i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a
glorious day we're down here yeah cody's
timeshare
we didn't get remodeled we relocated for
a couple of days today got a timeshare
she went to the pitch she thought she
was just gonna use it for the trip to
florida but they sold her hook line and
sinking you bought into it ah they saw a
whale walking a lot when she rolled in
yeah i see one right now
time shared down in houston and she
found out skankfest was here oh baby
first weekend we're down here having a
good time it's a good time my co-host is
coming at you from across the chair i
mean i just felt very phil donahue right
this is my co-host
i feel like we're gonna read dna tests
later
kevin james ryan is here everybody hey
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true
[ __ ] cooking baby and then i would be
a [ __ ] [ __ ] if i didn't mention
the greatest website of all time
patreon.com
check it out you get all the [ __ ]
bonus content videos episodes live
streams the whole nine yards over 100
million hours of bonus content
100
best in the business
except tim dillon and andrew schultz
come down and and matt and shane other
than that we're doing all right
and speaking of which i have a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man he set this
whole thing up all right great job buddy
yeah we love you t-bone mcmuffin it's
toby mcmullen god damn it yeah they said
it was good so i don't even know [ __ ] in
the youtube comments
dude this is sick dude talk about the
mutants at table nine skank fest is
popping yeah that's why it's a wild
scene over there it's a [ __ ] neck
tattoo convention i feel attractive yeah
foley's a skankfest nine
i'll take it gang we could not be more
excited to have an incredibly special
guest back with us again today down here
in houston with us he is the host of the
josh potter show ladies and gentlemen mr
josh potter what's up
[Laughter]
you got two bud lights in your hair
you didn't do that ironically
i'm still holding that over that one in
the
blood the blinds or the frogs those
budweiser frogs were pretty good
they were cooking what does it say about
us as a society when that kind of [ __ ]
sweeps us up the california raisins were
all dancing around
the budweiser frogs just they ran so bad
baby can you know whatever she does yeah
exactly
the predecessor to bad baby catch me
outside how about that
that was a new budweiser
this is the first time we're in person
the last time we had the first time
yeah yeah
this is great yeah thanks for having me
you were early on too you were probably
yeah two summers ago right it was
during the quarantine i know that yeah
um
and you had one of my favorites just to
touch on
that you said you grew up
by an off-ramp i grew up on a four-lane
highway
he said he could see he could see the
dolphins that's right we could hear i
fell asleep to the sounds of trucks
downshifting
fell asleep to the sounds of all the
exact change
get out of here yeah they still have
toll booth workers in those toll booths
it's not like you throw it in the it's
not like the carnival game ones yeah the
ring toss they have people that give you
the tickets and take your money and
everything like that i saw the hottest
chick i've ever seen in one of those
toll booths really to the point where i
gave her the money and i was like so i'm
like what the [ __ ] is going and i left
and i wanted to like go back yeah yeah
you know what i mean i forgot something
just to be like why are you yeah
or like what are you doing here yeah
yeah dude i've had that same kind of
thought process my entire life whenever
i go into
um
the mcdonald's on west 4th street had
this girl that worked there that was
literally a [ __ ] supermodel and then
there was a cvs around the corner in the
west village that had another girl same
supermodel i wanted to look and be like
what are you doing working here yeah
yeah hasn't anybody seen you ever what's
happening did you hear them speak at all
no
if they had a certain uh affection maybe
you'd be like oh
that's why they work here there's
probably some some neck tattoos missing
a couple that'll be 48.50 jesus christ
she's smoking hot but she's missing a
few chromosomes
uh also too i wanted to bring up there
was one that you i like how kippy's
holding quarterback i feel these chairs
really i feel powerful really dude i
feel like a sports fighter
give or make the five on cleveland
what's the deal
white howard's out tonight
kippy what's your take on that
well you know foley
uh no you uh cause people we were
talking about it i think it was do you
pull uh and then everyone's like you
gotta have you gotta talk to people oh
my god that's right do you pull you
tried to call you we were gonna call you
all in air the one time okay um but it
was like do you unbutton when you're out
of your oh we had a whole debate on my
podcast about this so it's when you're
out of urinal you go through the fly
over do you unbutton
people like you gotta talk to [ __ ]
people yeah i did a whole uh study on
this and because i'm a i'll say what i
am immediately i'm a through the fly guy
wow
and when i heard that there are so many
over the i did a poll and i did multiple
polls 60 to 40 people go over the top
really i found out i'm in the rare a
rare breed i thought i was the most
common i don't i don't mean to discredit
your scientific establishment sure or
the scientists that you employed this
isn't a wuhan situation i'm not accusing
okay but there's no way the number's
that high nobody goes through the fly no
no no i'm doing the reverse
i was i was in the minority yeah oh okay
40 most people go through that that's
what i'm saying yes still even 40
there's no way 40 percent goes through
the fly i it's you and another guy the
way that this guy is at home
it's you and one dude that works in a
bowling alley i understood what he said
i'm saying the numbers are juice it's
still high i see the way that this came
up i was on a family vacation oh god and
uh you can't pull other potters
other potters can't be the tesla it's in
your bloodline you all go through the
hole one of my cousins and i were like
everyone are we are we talking about
over the jeans or over the the underwear
i mean just completely i i don't know
what you animals do when you go
i go through the fly both holes really
this guy's crawling through the water
yeah yeah i mean i you're snaking it
yeah that's a lot of zigzags you got to
go back and forth a couple of times you
must be packing some heat pops i found
the shortcut well that's what i said too
but somebody was like it's big dick
energy to go over kelsey cook came on
she was like i think it's big dick
energy to go over the top and i'm like
don't come on here and slander under my
average unit yeah exactly i can also
refute that because
i go over the top and uh i have no dick
energy here's what i don't understand do
you undo the whole belt and everything i
do so i do undo the whole belt and then
i'll go over the underwear
that's just such wild that's not that's
normal that's what a normal guy would do
that doesn't make any sense to me i just
go zip i pull it out i've done i've done
experiments with these these jeans on my
show where i've zipped the fly i'm like
i can put my whole arm through this why
are people scared about their dick
hitting the zipper like what kind of
animal are you with your dick
that is i do see what you're saying i
think for maybe a while i would go i
don't know
but why is the fly there then it's it's
like when you get to buy a cheap tuxedo
and they put that fake uh handkerchief
in there that doesn't go anywhere yeah
that's so it is it's just for show man
it's just for show yes it's just for
show i just don't understand if it's
would you wear boxers or box what do you
wear i wear boxer bricks that's even
crazier they still have a fly if you
wore yeah but it's it's it
it's not straight that's a you gotta you
gotta go if you have a boxer it's all
right that's like now i will say this
it's a straight shot through yeah as a
blind man i'm often doing things
without looking so i can probably
navigate
a fly like that pretty quickly without
looking at it by my sister
his other senses have developed my other
that's like denzel washington putting a
gun together
my senses are heightened as terms of
touch and feel so i can [ __ ]
daredevil over here yeah exactly but i
couldn't believe the study and what i've
what i've
studied it's all right it's not a study
what i've deduced though is that
you asked a bunch of your dirtbag
cousins at a cookout yeah
hey they all go through the fly we were
in daytona beach and they all like
mayonnaise sandwiches which is weird two
of the cousins are kissing
we were like but i swear to god i i i
this is my takeaway from it that we who
go through the fly though rare
are more he's treats dude he's so
[ __ ] well once again take above take
over
we're more of a it's it's the same thing
as like mcdonald's sells a million
hamburgers a day how many people are
eating rib eyes a day
that's the way i look at it ribeye
steaks yes it's a little more
you know just because it's not done
amongst the collective unwashed
necessarily they're you know we're still
upper crust you know what i'm saying
that's what it is that says so much
about how garbage you are that the rib
eye's the one that you went with
you didn't do fillet yeah
you can have hamburger you can have some
hanger steak
some good stomach either your chuck
wagon or your flank steak
in my world baby shout out to flagstick
nothing wrong with it
skirt steak
skirt steak's big around my place yeah
my stepdad and some skirt steak forget
about it did your mom do london broil
when you were young that was like the
big thing with us a london broil i got a
london broil yeah yeah that was just
that big log of meat right no idea
it seems very fancy well london you
think london you go that's fantastic
royal you're not just bro you don't bore
your life seems like a fancy word i
don't know how to prepare something yeah
but all it is is like a [ __ ] it's like
the other side of the new york strip on
a cow
you know what my mom only made growing
up was that chicken that you'd put in a
bag with carrots and [ __ ] dude chicken
in a bag and it would be in a bag it was
chicken it was chicken it seems like the
plastics
you're going through a chemical change
on that plastic they say don't even
reuse a bottle of water like now we're
cooking in a bag they're unbelievable
it's they do a chicken one and they do a
pot roast one my mom used to do that too
it's still in like a tray
but it's all in a bad hiat's garbage
yeah what are you talking about yeah and
then you cut that like wet sweaty bag up
i can feel whatever you wanted to stand
around while your mom cut it like yeah
my mom still can only cook like with
thanksgiving so my sister and i made my
mom stop cooking on thanksgiving we're
like we'll get bob evans like whatever
stop cooking so you guys do order you
order in now yeah we just we get or we
go to a different fam my mom she would
cook she would think she was cooking
she'd be microwaving like canned green
beans oh
they turn real green i brought a
girlfriend home bob evans on
thanksgiving or what is it boston market
maybe i don't know that's worse i think
to be honest i think boston the best
thanksgiving ever had i lived in
cleveland and i got three family meals
of boston market thanksgiving and i
watched it was the first year they did
three football games on thanksgiving
and i watched them right hotter
it was the best
it was the you're the same the horrible
remember the harbol it was john harbaugh
versus jim harbaugh san francisco who
are you with you got three of them by
himself oh it's all alone yeah for
dessert he made pipe bombs
[Laughter]
oh my god my apartment looked like that
apartment at the time was an air
mattress a lamp in a television set that
sat next to the air mattress
and i swear to god i had the cops called
on me like four times because people
thought i was squatting in there yeah
that or you're playing in the next 911
[ __ ] it was a basement it was one of
those basement ones too so you had to
like the windows were at the roof oh
subterraneous yeah yeah that's good you
see the footsteps dude
there's dogs peeing in your window and
stuff that's a house that gets swatted
yeah you just see feet walk by it was so
weird watching feet walk by and
a hobo takes a piss on your oh mommy who
lives there nobody lives there honey
there was no carpet either tile floor
right it was all actually carpet that's
even and the
uh the appliances were immaculate i
never used them but they were wonderful
the kitchen appliances they were the
steel ones the stainless steel ones yeah
yeah first time i've ever had those have
kind of uh
people are figuring that out they got
yeah they're slapping them on shitty
ones yeah yeah yeah they're like
televisions they're just as cheap as 100
yeah
oh yeah what the [ __ ] [ __ ] sweet
i did want to ask you that
um
as you said pods working out very well a
couple of bucks coming in yes new money
so two questions one was there an
irrational huge purchase at any time
ever like you ever get like a one big
check from someone you're like i'm gonna
do this i this is the one time probably
and i haven't uh i'll say i did one
responsible thing i paid off my credit
card which is like it's great the most
successful thing i ever had that was at
like seven grand okay and i paid it down
from it was the only i only had this
credit card when i moved to l.a wait did
you not pay it so let me no i paid it
off i'll say it started at 15 grand and
i was paying it off over four years i
got it down to like half and then i just
paid it the rest of it love that
power do you want to know what i was 15
you know how i racked up that debt it
was simply i moved to la four years ago
i had none of this debt and i had no job
and i made myself two venmo accounts so
that i could commit credit card fraud
against myself essentially one forward
like cash advances from my credit card
to myself via venmo and avoid the fees
and venmo caught me and shut me down but
i was giving myself money
from my credit card into my bank i think
what saying hey this is not like i was
venmoing myself yes but then would you
say like i didn't authorize this charge
toby no no i would i would i would say
that i authorized it but i was avoiding
the fees do you know what i mean like oh
i see what you're saying and so venmo
caught me and they were like you can't
do that you should have been like no
well if i i can't you're avoiding the
credit card fees by taking
i was basically going yes i was going
like five hundred dollars to myself then
going to the atm and having the five
hundred dollars yes exactly and that and
the credit card company wasn't charging
right 515 dollars right and they caught
me that's pretty [ __ ] good i gotta
give you that make you pay it back or
anything no it's just ven moment we shut
down the one account and it's bad when
venmo calls you it's like hey you gotta
knock it off yeah not the rest worker or
anything like that you know
wait you're just a broke podcaster yeah
yeah wait you're not blowing anybody for
this money
i'm sorry i can't have you i paid my
rent with that credit card for like
eight months though
oh just off cash
yeah yeah so but you have a fifteen
thousand dollar credit limit
uh i had a higher one than that and then
uh because my mother's name was attached
to the paypal got a whole she didn't
know that uh goddamn cash had their
hands all over me i had a menage showed
up and arrested you that was the thing
so this credit card was like i think
like my mom gave me a credit card a long
time ago when i was like she was she was
garbage she did the thing where she was
trying to make her credit better so
she's putting it in my name
when i was like a baby had this girl
so
i said this is the time to use it i'm
moving to la i need this to advance my
life and so she let me have it and then
when it got up to 10 grand she started
freaking out
and she was like creating a monster yeah
you're hurting my credit too so i
stopped using it and i paid her i paid
it off though all at once but then the
other thing i did was all right so
that's the responsible thing there was a
girl that i've always wanted to sleep
with from back home
that uh we have always talked or
whatever i flew her to la i got a room
at the ritz what yeah and then uh we had
a great time
she didn't [ __ ] me we had a nice time
she did though
don't listen to this fat bastard
you had sex with the ritz hell yeah
that's what i'm talking about that's new
money love that it was it felt just
opulent it was wonderful
did you tell her it was from podcast
money she knows
she's watching right now i love you baby
what was that that was a weekend it was
uh it was just this past monday tuesday
oh it's just now yeah oh this you're
just coming up i just got the money
i still own a rich three grand
i gotta call them up yeah they'll take
care of that
yeah it was just this past monday monday
night tuesday night wow monday tuesday
dude talk about new money kitty cat kid
gets a check
flies out the girl that he's always had
a crush on from high school to the ritz
holy bangs are in the wrist on a monday
it wasn't high school but you know what
a long time ago yeah yeah yeah high
school would have made it more romantic
she was just some bartender from back
home
but i've always had a crush on though
she's she's beautiful
she's lovely yeah not just a bartender
what did that what did that cost you all
told i didn't throw the whole weekend
get it but probably
you have a rough probably three grand
with everything including because i this
is what i did dude baller move i flew i
didn't get her first class ticket but i
gave her like extra leg room felt the
comforter a little uh
i upped her to base you know a little
higher than basic economy that's all
how'd you like that extra bag of cheese
i bet that made you wet right you come
out of ropes do you feel good about that
exit room
but i also you know what i did i got the
uh the town car whoa
wait with the sign yes no way but dude
get this this is what i found out too
i don't know if you've ever tried to
uber out of lax
but it's not much more expensive just to
get a [ __ ] town
car yeah it's only like 80 more to get a
town car did the guy have the signing
yes i had him go inside josh's girl yeah
let him go inside with it and everything
hey buffalo [ __ ]
i'm kidding i'm sorry we got a ball
for just a bartender yeah you're talking
about my future wife
[Laughter]
how dare you
dude that's see that's what i'm [ __ ]
talking about that's the answer i've
been looking for
asking that question for the last
[ __ ] season that's amazing i'd like
to do something else fun with it i came
here that was part of yeah if i came
here hanging that's [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah no that's too normal let's get
crazy like you know as a road comic you
know sometimes you can't go to all the
places you'd like to go you know you
have to go to the gigs and then you're
stuck until the next yeah yeah yeah it
was cool to get to come down here and
hang out it's awesome
i love that dude that's that might be
that's one of the best answers we've
ever had i think [ __ ] the fact that
it was this week i'm chubbing up over
here yeah dude it's just happened
because
i'm so stoked campbell's talking about
the good people at ladder oh yeah
uh you want to make sure your uh things
are in order gang term life insurance is
something you got to look into and
ladder makes it easy
got to check them out yeah it's 100
digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for three
million dollars in coverage or less just
need a few minutes and a phone or a
laptop and ladder smart algorithms work
in real time so you find out if you're
instantly approved if you prefer to talk
to a person their license team of agents
doesn't work on commission so they'll
help you and not upsell you they'll get
what's right for you no hidden fees the
whole nine yards finally since life
insurance costs more as you age now is
the time to cross it off your list so go
to ladderlife.com garbage today to see
if you're instantly approved that's
ladder l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it
yeah can't be like a little dad grass
or mom grass or mom grass either one i
know back in my day i used to like to
puff the chiba uh-huh smoke to doobie
sure pull some bong hits i'm listening
but nowadays you really don't want that
heavy high feeling you're a mature man
now but with that grass
it's like having just a nice glass of
wine rather than the whole bottle
absolutely fantastic yeah dad grass is
legal organic smokable hemp that relaxes
your body mellows your mind 100 organic
pre-roll joints are very low in thc but
high in cbd so you can enjoy the effects
of cbd while keeping your egg clean keep
the egg clear don't get all too fogged
up all that grass products are federally
legal for ages 21 and over and chips
right to your door anywhere in the good
old us of a right now dadgrass is
offering our listeners 20
off your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com garbage go to
dadgrass.com
garbage 20 off your first order one more
time write it down dadgrass.com garbage
do it i was gonna ask you i know you're
mostly a homebody mm-hmm but well the
well the because this is just the first
in a long line things are gonna be
much better from now on sure checks
ain't stopping nobody's coming in yes
exactly now will you start to
a little more fine dining a little more
i'm not your diet's not great i do like
a restaurant no my diet's actually not
terrible i'm not a garbage food person
necessarily i have like
was the best thanksgiving ever
[Laughter]
they had three games on they had bears
they had the browns played it was a
great ball baby
i uh i mean my diet's not terrible i do
like going out to dinner though what's
up what's like a dinner
i'm sorry you know a [ __ ] a ribbon
you know i uh
no i do like a steak someone made fun of
me because i uh i was out with uh with
with tom segura this past weekend and we
went out to dinner every time i mean the
dinner's there what's that yeah that's
gotta be bonco that's crazy it's
unbelievable you go out to dinner it's
got you know the everything's got
truffles i mean i don't know
everything's the truffle's got trouble
troublesome
yeah do you want you want sparkling
water with truffles i mean that's crazy
but uh i always get a statement
i'm sorry is sparking water foreign to
you i love it when they have when they
go sparkling or tap i go this is a nice
place
[Laughter]
they all do it now i'm tipping 12 here
and a wendy's really all right oh and
then they got the glass bottles yeah no
those are bad you always get
the not you're saying the sparkling in
the glass yeah yes of course but when
the when the when the restaurant just
has regular tap water in like an old
wine bottle never do it no no they got
to have a seal of course yeah that's
true no i'm learning
[Laughter]
fool me once you know what i like doing
too i'm learning too i like doing like i
went to the ritz you know and i
i go in there i'm really pretty womaning
this whole thing you know what i mean
like i walk in i look like this yeah i
feel like they're gonna tell me to get
the hell out well it's also i've been
like when we go to we'll go to like nice
places dressed like [ __ ] idiots yeah
and i just i just
i
dude look at us we look like [ __ ]
idiots i'm like they don't know we could
be bitcoin rich you know what i mean
that's what i say they go i could be on
tick-tock yeah they [ __ ] know what's
calling these guys yeah yeah what if i'm
a rapper
you could be i could be a little dicky
or some [ __ ] they don't [ __ ] know
that you're importing some day bartender
well that's the other fear they go i
don't want them to think i'm a
sex trafficker
just eastern european women following
you
be very alert going through the lobby
oh my god that's too funny so you are
stepping out a little bit more i i am
having a great deal of fun a great deal
i love that yeah do you feel the pallets
getting a little more expanded yeah i
know are you trying new things i love
trying all the new things i don't like
lobster i've learned i'm a crab guy i
like crab i think that's just how
trashy we are genetically generationally
like yes if uh lobster i just don't get
them like but i'll take [ __ ] crab
what do you like about lobster the
autopsy part of it i just can't the
autopsy part of it
i don't like taking its [ __ ] out of its
butt i don't like uh it's my favorite
part seeing its eyes yeah it's looking
at me it's just all there and you gotta
like conduct this like
you're breaking it and [ __ ] i can't
i can't do it it's like crabs it's just
legs so you don't even know you're just
like oh okay yeah you don't know where
this came from it's like chicken wings
you know what i mean
they don't put the beak on there
[Laughter]
chicken wings of the sea yeah
it's got sunglasses on them
well that's good oh god but yeah i don't
uh i i'm trying to think of any like
extravagant foods i have had lately and
i i just can't feel it's pretty good
yeah the truffle caviar sushi are you
super oh i love well west coast that's
the thing all the seafood is sushi so i
mean really you can get some garbage
sushi too whereas like east coast
seafood i miss a lot crab clams that
kind of [ __ ] i would just love to have a
bucket of [ __ ] clams they don't have
that [ __ ] in la you know i love like a
clam bake because what's a normal dinner
when you're at home by yourself what
would you be making oh i just eat i eat
like a can of tuna fish i ate like the
[ __ ] like i'm in taxi driver
i'm like [ __ ] psychopath
do you eat out of the can oh yeah really
i i don't like dishes
man you don't put anything on it salt
pepper i do a little olive oil and uh
some salt you don't do the you don't get
the tuna that's in olive oil right you
get the tuna in water yeah okay drain
the water drain the water you ever see
that would you ever give or by accident
buy one where it's tuna and oil
uh i don't know that i have dude it's
[ __ ] disgusting
no man have you ever bought salmon in a
can
by accident
i gave it to the cat
i thought i was being fancy doing it
what what
i'm like oh i love how his brain works i
thought i was being fancy getting salmon
in a can well you know they got the
albacore they got the
salmon i thought the salmon was like
next level up sure oh yes my lady i'll
have the pellegrino please what do you
have in a can tonight
it's real good it's mostly net
they get out most of the net
it says some dolphin
hey i got a bobber in mine
hey we're trying our best
a bobber ooh allure
[Laughter]
all right let's get into some cues oh
yeah oh my god i got you here buddy
thank you for coming down thanks for
having us this is nice
this is great um ah guys so as you know
when you join the patreon we will answer
your garbage question on air we get
flooded with a bunch of them this is
just the best way to do it we appreciate
all the support as always patreon gets
first crack at it because they're the
homies the homies dressy or bozo bozo
but we love all these obviously of
course um this one's just a home run
this is from david smith uh it just says
car freshener somewhere other than a car
that's got to be yeah you got one in the
closet or something
next to your suit that's just deodorant
oh my god you remember those uh
do you have a favorite air freshener by
the way flavor
yeah i'll i'll go like i'll typically
wait hold on are we talking about the
car just in general i'm talking air
freshener car okay
i'll typically go old school like the
lemons like the yellow one or it's
always the tree the tropical mist or
whatever there's a there's like a little
baby blue tropical something not trying
to breeze or something not trying to get
problematic but there is a
flavor i don't know if flavor is the
right word
but
eats them so yeah
i like the turkey dinner but the uh the
scent of it's called black ice oh that's
the trashiest one dude
that was the best one
it's so tragic it smells like a it's
like mike epps is driving my car
like the coolest black guy ever is
driving this car that's the way i don't
know this smells like a cool black guy i
just think every time i've gotten in
someone with black that like all my
friends would have it growing up it's
like it just smells like blunts it just
smells like black and it's like hell
yeah yeah i just equate it with like
yeah this is like this is an immature
guy riding around listening to rap
smoking no but the origin of it the
origin of it when it first came out it
was hot it was cool because it did have
the cool black guy smell yeah it's
almost it has a very dracar noir yeah
yeah which i think is trashy as well no
it's not classical now it is because
it's because it's been it's been used
but back in the day
see that one dude that's got that on
that nobody else had it on [ __ ] chain
killing it to run the but i do do real
cool i did put the black ice air
freshener in my bathroom what
as like a air freshener yeah i didn't
mean anything you did it as for
decoration yeah
because i love the smell of it so much
i'm like i want my bathroom to smell
like wow but then i it doesn't work i
mean
it's the [ __ ] zombie it smells like
an uber in here
how long have you been driving for lyft
you got floor mats in the tub
the
toilet has those beads
there's a steering wheel cover on the
knobs
um do you have a car i don't i haven't
driven a car since i moved to l.a i
thought that was the city where you have
to drive yeah i uh i take uh public
transit and i walk
and i
take ubers i just uh i said when i moved
no more driving partly because of the
eyes oh yeah it's probably because of
the i'm bad at it anyhow and i got some
things
i was driving around like i got some
things i used to freeze over that i was
poor i used to drive around a lot with
like inspections being sure
a lot of suspended license arrests in my
past so i was like i don't even want to
bother with it so when i moved i said i
wouldn't drive now the idea of driving a
car terrifies me honestly when you get
away from it a little bit yeah i don't i
honestly don't like driving that much it
scares me everybody's a maniac out there
yeah i don't even it's so funny uh
brandon schaub had that story where he
like saved children from a burning car
do you see that story yeah i vaguely
remember that he was like driving by and
they saw a burning car in this child or
whatever holy [ __ ] i'm thinking in my
head like
i ride around on ubers all the time with
my headphones i'm just looking at my
phone they're saying stuff to me even if
a guy was like there's a burning car
over there would have been like uh-huh i
would have just like looked at my phone
how long have you been driving for uber
yeah yeah i wouldn't have even answered
him like that i would have just been
like uh-huh i would have been like
double tapping on some ass on instagram
hey bozo make it right on fairfax right
here how often would i just not even
notice that even if i was driving that's
what i and then you know so i i don't
want to drive a [ __ ] car ever again i
i'ma stop i like that when it comes to
things like that i'm a stopper usually
unless it's real hairy but no matter
whether i'm driving i'd like to hope i
was a stopper but i don't know that i
wouldn't notice it that's the other
thing
i don't think i can really help in those
situations so i'm like what do you mind
if you pull by there there was people i
mean like if you're like proper first
[ __ ] if it happens in front of you and
i'm like
but if i'm sitting in traffic and then i
i'm like the 50th car to pass someone
you know there's someone's rocked they
got it
what am i gonna do you get out of the
uber and walk that's the worst when you
leave an uber driver hanging in traffic
i've done that oh my god yeah i'm like
buddy i gotta go i'm sorry i almost got
mad at you yeah i put you in this
position and now you're turning the
meter off i've done that to make spots
for sure i've gotten out and run
at the uh
to make a spot oh yeah yeah for sure
um damn that's a good one this is from
sausage and peppers you ever have gum
stuck in your hair oh [ __ ] yeah
well what do you do to get it out the
peanut butter that's the thing yeah
there's that or i think my sister used
to use uh
is there a cream of some kind or
whatever
[Music]
he just said that like you were british
i don't have any hairstyles
[Laughter]
i think ice would work too ice maybe ice
yes like a water i think just water i've
heard ice my aunt would do hellman's
mayonnaise
specifically helmets i'd rather just
have the gum
[Laughter]
yeah right god damn that's like what you
do if you get sprayed by a skunk
tomato chips
have you ever been sprayed by a skunk uh
i've had dogs get sprayed by skunks i
never but basically that's like the same
thing put lettuce at tomato on them
i've had to clean my dog with tomato
juice a couple times yeah tomatoes back
home yeah that's a [ __ ] what are you
doing in the bat you feel sometimes i'm
like it doesn't smell it just smells
like bong hits i'm like i don't care let
them be but my mom yeah
the dogs get dogs got some pretty good
bud on them
my dog's just loud
yo damn who's your who's your plug now
um that's trash i'm satin gum on the
train oh that [ __ ] sucks yeah where
you like stand up and you're like ah
stepping in it's bad too where you just
like see it you're like what would you
rather step in gum or dog [ __ ] dude i
step in dog [ __ ] five or six times a
year i was just gonna brand it's always
brand new shoes and i throw them out
right away throw the shoes out yeah just
you don't even try to sell i'm never
gonna get them back i'm never gonna get
them to the point where i don't know
they were covered in dog [ __ ] uh i was
just gonna say that i haven't stepped in
dog [ __ ] in probably 30 years you guys
live in new york how are dogs are [ __ ]
on the sidewalk everywhere yeah 30 years
i've been like i swear to god i feel
like i haven't slept in dog [ __ ] in 30
years i had a bird [ __ ] on me a couple
weeks ago
that's good luck it's good luck
but it's awesome disgusting
what i said we could use the good luck
if you got it
pull that card where did it land the
bird [ __ ] landed on my bucky's hat oh
you got to be a bucky's fan yeah is that
when you're in the south wait bucky's
it's like the
we caught like a redneck wawa kind of
i'm a shony's guy what's shony no that's
oh man you're real trash
what the [ __ ] is a show bucky's is like
a convenience store oh it's like a gas
station it's like on the highway and
it's they have like
where receptionists go to cheat on their
husbands
on wednesday
shony's is like a low-class perkins
oh my god no it's not perkins is a low
classic same yeah it's at the same level
perkins is a high class i think would
even be a little bit it goes perkins
denny's shonies i don't know about that
i think
perkins with the bread bowls their menu
was so expensive their menu was so
expensive they were like the cheesecake
factory of diners oh my gosh
i think shony's has uh stuffed mushrooms
though
establishment when they got that good
shakes out of shonies too
and a claw machine always
i'm mean on a claw machine i can't
believe you've never seen a shony's
thing i don't know where they are
they're only in the south no there was
there was one in philly for a little
while we used to go in college all the
time i never heard of it
not as classy as the hula hands
holy hands
that's like legit happy hour [ __ ] 80s
kind of move right there yeah hola hands
was great yeah big fan a lot of hell of
a chicken finger in that place
i don't know what they put in that honey
mustard but it was delicious
um i assume i know you like you like a
nice bud light from time to time this
one's from frank uh you ever use a beer
to take a vitamin or a pill yes really a
lot i've i've shot guns i've shot gun
beers to take xanax what just for fun i
mean that was yeah it sounds like a hoot
yeah it was just for like yeah we don't
need you driving anywhere yeah i don't
think about it i don't want that's the
point i was like it's such a relief off
my shoulders knowing that's not an
opportunity yeah like you'll never get a
dui yeah yeah it's probably yeah again
exactly i don't i got the first one yeah
i just i assumed i took one look at you
guys yeah i know i got i got one back in
ought nine ought nine yeah but to be
clear i think kevin met like a tylenol
or something like that no this the
question actually was daily
vulnerability for antidepressants i have
taken just uh tylenol pm or an advil
with a beer too yeah i've done advil
with beers yeah yeah put you out night
night exactly go sleepy bye
[Laughter]
man we say that a lot on the show
that's so weird night with my dad
uh what is your method of taking a pill
this was big what do you mean by that
pop it in your mouth take a drink of
water i can dry them i do i do dry
parkour they're backing it can you drink
can
i can do multiple drives too like yeah
tablets i can do the whole thing yeah
sometimes you get a little ha it's up in
here somewhere but you get it down they
say that's terrible for you is it yeah
you're supposed to take it with water
for like the digestion and like how the
medicine breaks up and i'll literally
just pop it in my mouth a woman told me
one time at an office that i worked at
for like three months that if you take
tylenol with a diet coke it works faster
and probably the bubbles probably
dissolve it quicker yeah yeah that makes
sense so then i was i was doing that for
a minute too she wasn't a doctor
she she had the same job as i did she
was a joni
you know if you take those with diet
coke they hit you
[Laughter]
i'll bring the nachos i want to try that
theory with all the pills
that's trash oh man
gang let's talk about brooklyn oh baby
brook linen let's talk about self-care
let's talk about the long year that it's
been the ups and downs that we've gone
through self-care has got to be one of
them and that starts with a good night's
sleep it starts with betting
get good betting they got good betting
they got good towels too they sent me a
whole box of them john's yeah they do i
feel like i'm gonna feel like i'm at the
ritz carlton baby
treat yourself pamper yourself with a
little brook linen yeah brooklyn was
started to create beautiful high quality
home essentials that don't cost an arm
and a leg and people let me tell you
what a success they're cooking uh they
have something for every comfort you
need ideal for uh you know
if they're launching new products colors
patterns the whole nine yards i'm
talking buttery soft breathable sheets
because that's how i talk plush and
absorbent towels cozy robes comfy sauce
comfy loungewear i like butter uh you'll
want to put it on and never take it off
uh like i said they sent us a whole box
me and my lady are we using it it's
great super soft oh plush kippy likes it
plush uh so give yourself the comfort
refresh you deserve and get it for less
at brooklyn and go to brooklyn.com use
our promo code garbage for 20 off with a
minimum minimum purchase of 100
that's brooklyn and
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
enter promo code garbage for 20 off with
a minimum purchase of a hondo that's
brooklyn.com promo code garbage do it
yeah i'm ready
to keep my privacy
with expressvpn uh-huh because when
you're surfing the net you're exposed oh
baby you're like a live wire anybody
could sneak in there
with your pants down what's literally
literally
get caught with your pants down now i'm
the tech guy around here so i know about
this kind of sure you need a vpn and
express can help you out turns out that
incognito mode for your online activity
still gets tracked data brokers still
buy and sell your data day to day every
day every minute and they're just
stacking it they're piling it up every
time you connect to expressvpn you get a
random ip address shared by many other
users of expressvpn uh that makes it
harder for third parties to identify and
harvest your data
there's losing the tail you know what i
mean yeah when the feds are on your town
shake them shake em that's right run it
you gotta be able to stick and move
burning red lights that's what
expressvpn does best of all expressvpn
is super easy to use no matter what
device you're on phone laptop smart tv
all you have to do is one top of the
button instant protection so if you
really want to go incognito mode and
protect your privacy secure yourself
with the number one rated vpn visit
expressvpn.com garbage and get three
extra months for free that's express e x
p r e s s v p n dot com slash garbage go
to expressvpn.com to learn more back to
the shop incognito mode
um
this has been big uh
first of all do you sneak food into a
movie theater i have i like more
sneaking beers into the movies jesus
christ i'm not a snacks guy really yeah
i like i'm not like canned i don't
really i'm not big on candy or anything
but i'll sneak all the beers in the in
the movie thing they never got drinking
at the movies i like it
yeah do you watch tv and drink
sometimes yeah
it's a way bigger tv what are we talking
about i know but there's a bunch of kids
around eating candy and watching toy
story you haven't been to my house
you go to toy story
i could yeah yeah that's not something
you drink at if you're going to you know
um i've never gone to a kids movie in a
theater i don't think but yeah that's
i'm usually going to see like it's
pretty saw or some [ __ ] like that and
you just crack a few beers there you go
all right that'll get murdered i've i've
been
i've been so drunk like you go obviously
drunk you've been drinking yeah you get
there you're sneaking some beers you're
having some pops in there and then
you're like yo it's time for a ciggy
we would sneak out and then like you
can't leave and then really come back so
we would just like
pop out like the fire exit and just like
oh the one where the shooters come in
yeah exactly
just chain smoke a [ __ ] sig and then
[ __ ] flicker you can't do that now
yeah people would freak the [ __ ] out i
had sex in a movie theater and recently
no this is back right before i moved to
la 2017 this was the best
public sex ever in the history of my
life this is [ __ ] this guy's steamy
dude i i made this like joke to this
girl about the alanis morissette song
you know like did she go down on you in
a theater i was like i want to do that
to a girl shout out to joey gladstone i
want to go down on a girl in a theater
that's what i said to this girl
in the theater i said i want to i want
to do that in a movie theater like that
song to a girl though and she was like
let's do it so i scheduled
it was the movie was phoenix rising
do you remember that movie i don't it
was like a fountain
the x-men but this is the point no it's
a harry potter it was like a found
footage alien movie
in 2017
and uh basically i picked the movie that
i never heard of before on the list sure
and then i picked it up a matinee yeah
so it was 12 30 in the afternoon on like
a monday that's real creepy and there
was no one there and we went into the
back back corner and just went at it it
was the best and then the movie was
i mean we were like seven minutes of the
movie by the time we were done yeah you
gotta watch it [ __ ] well then i go
we just walked out cause i'm like i
don't wanna see this [ __ ]
so i wonder what they thought you know
when we were leaving but we just got out
of there real quick what'd you do with
the twizzlers and stuff like that never
did see that movie by the way i never we
didn't buy any snacks
popcorn yeah snuck in a couple of beers
though
i can't perform unless i got a couple in
me
get a couple milk donuts though i had to
walk out though going like that thing's
trash you know what i mean about the
movie yeah man no wonder it was empty
that thing you should have got your
money back this is that would have been
that would have been a move right there
will you do that at a restaurant or a
bar or like anything will you no will
you complain or ask for i'm a simp i'll
[ __ ] over tip even when it's yeah i'm
the same way i just had an uber driver
the other night i was so pissed because
it was like
the arrival time just kept stacking up
and up and up uber [ __ ] is dude they're
tired the conception of time now is
horrible brutal so i'm just losing my
mind i'm like oh my god oh my god the
driver pulls up it's a cute girl i'm
listening and she's like i'm sorry and
i'm like it's okay yeah i don't care you
want me to drive and i had the setting
it was like quiet and cool you know like
the temperature and the you know the
conversation i just didn't want i always
put quiet and she goes how's your day
and i was like oh it's been great how's
your day and she's talking she goes oh
i'm sorry it says quiet i go oh i don't
even pay attention i don't even know
what that is
and she didn't have any sense of urgency
she drove 30 miles an hour on the
highway there was no traffic i was so
late for dinner and
i still tipped her five stars yeah i
[ __ ] gave her a fat tip because i'm a
simp yeah i get it that's but i'll over
tip a waitress even if they [ __ ] it up
it's always my fault for maybe i didn't
speak clearly enough or whatever you
know will you send something back can
you do that or do you just take if it's
like egregious i mean like it has to be
like there has to be a human finger
severed in mind sure in my soup for me
and even then i would still say
something i'm like sorry about it
i thought it might have been mine but i
got all ten and uh i thought yeah i
counted i got them i think he's married
because there is a wedding right you
might wanna you might wanna alert the
family yeah i do not like doing that
just because i mean i my parents were
diner yeah yeah yeah yeah
remember that yeah 100
um
have you ever checked into a hotel room
and then changed rooms been like this no
no i can't do that either because then i
feel like they're going to catch me and
feel like i don't belong in the hotel
the ritz i was i was getting a little uh
a couple of side eyes i was getting a
little ritzy at the ritz i kept going
like this air conditioner is not to my
liking and i thought about it you get
real rich when you start spending some
money like this is unsatisfactory yeah
yeah i thought about i'm like should i
switch rooms right now like no have the
girl come up and fluff my pillows they
might check they might check your
[ __ ] credit score or something out of
here i have that i have that problem in
a bank every time i go into a bank i'm
like they're because for so long i've
had to uh we were so poor and we had to
like yeah you know you're you're over
drafting but strategically for you know
like all this of course yeah you go like
well it'll lay over it yeah yeah
i'm getting
yeah that'll clean it up maybe if i do
it after nine the charge won't go
through until you know you play that
game
every time i walk into a bank i feel
like i'm robbing it i feel like they're
gonna be like step in here
you owe us ten thousand dollars on fees
you haven't paid your taxes in 17 years
like you're a piece of [ __ ] we've been
waiting for you get in here it's just i
had a i had one time i had a bank
account uh when i moved to cleveland
they didn't have the same bank that i
had so i had to open another account and
i just had such low credit and no money
that i thought i wasn't able to open a
bank account so my dad had a bank
account at pnc bank now my dad is no
less trash than i pnc bank is not a
great bank so he had a bank account
there so i would get my checks deposited
into that account that we joined
together okay my father didn't pay his
taxes
and they froze all his bank accounts
including mine then wow and that's when
i started getting like real scared about
bank then i started like taking money
out and like putting it in a jar
do you still hide money sometimes like i
used to be scared to look at my bank
account because i would be scared of
that neg that red number with the
negative next to it now though i like
look at it like four times a day i go
look at that that's crazy
and it's not even that crazy yeah of
course i go like i'll have a couple
thousand dollars ago i don't even need
to look you know what i mean like on a
weekend if i'm out spending them i go i
went to dinner and that was fun is that
when you guys don't even [ __ ] care
the check comes and you just go you
literally i go keep it yeah i don't even
just stuck in here run the car yeah
they're nice
run theirs too i don't care not looking
at the check and just handing it to them
or like popping a tip on there and just
going like whatever yeah but i had that
exact same thing happen with your dad
that happened to me with uh uh
pennsylvania it was years ago i had like
i just it was positive years ago i had
just deposited like a 700 check i had
700 bucks going into the weekend i felt
good like two hours later i looked and
it was gone and i called him like what
the [ __ ] happened they were like yeah
the uh the state took it from a back tax
so i had to call the state and tell and
like plead with them to put it back in
which it took like two weeks to put back
in it wasn't even worth it and i got
back like 23
or two hundred and thirty dollars for me
it was i i had just same thing i just
got in a deposit i put i think i just
did the revel casino and i had a 500
check that i just deposited from them
and i was like sweet the weekend's gonna
be good and i went just to get gas
and not even that much like 10 bucks and
it was like your car's decline your
car's a client and i'm looking at my
balance five you know 500 dollars just
that was the only thing in there is that
one check and then i called them and
they're like the irs is frozen your bank
account and i was like dad he's like
yeah hey
i'm on a plane to go to europe
my name's larry later nerd yeah he's
like was it weird
i don't know what could have happened
there huh
i can't hear you with the motor of the
speedboat yeah i'll call you back in a
minute when we get to land
i've said this when we started that's
got to be really bad though right right
that's got to be years what before they
do make a move like that right right
right he owed a lot of money like real
money it was yeah it was uh he owned a
business and it's all the best taxes and
then it was like hundreds of thousands
of taxes and so hundreds of thousands of
dollars in taxes yeah like he was like
looking at maybe jail and then he got
out of that part of it holy [ __ ]
so that's when they start raising red
flags like that yeah and it's also like
if you go to them and say like hey
listen
i may or may not have had some family
members and very similar
but there's a big thing too of it of
like if you're not they're they're
saying they'll they mail you a certified
letter and go hey you owe a hundred and
eighty thousand dollars in taxes penalty
interest is running contact us we can
work out a payment plan at least pay
down the principal at least pay the
penalties they work with you they'll
work with you because they're gonna go
like we know you don't have five hundred
thousand dollars if you did you would
pay us yeah so let's figure out how we
can get our money and if you just have
to be
open and like talk to them when you hide
for five years and then they go oh we'll
[ __ ] find you yeah we'll freeze your
[ __ ] you'll come call them real quick
yeah no [ __ ]
and then they work with you sort of and
then yeah i mean they're still [ __ ]
bending you over
but they'll work with you it's so funny
though then you look at your own like
with comedy or whatever you're like
there's a couple years there where i
missed and then you get it cleaned up
and you're like oh that's all it was
yeah i was sweating like 400
dude i got hit i knew i had something
sitting from the state of new york this
year and they were sending out the
uh refund checks oh i never got one
stimulus check by the way oh the
stimulus checks that's what i meant and
i'm like all right i got 750 coming i
don't know i don't i think maybe tag
something i don't know i didn't get a
single one not a one but i felt kind of
like good about it that i made it
through without getting them but i was
like bragging about i'm like i didn't
get any stimulus checks you're just all
my like i'm a patriot or something
i needed it
because now if they come after me i'm
like well
i mean we're even yeah it takes to 1400
or whatever it was yeah like they'll
care there's no way that argument's
gonna hold up what you got the stemies
yeah i thought we had an unspoken
agreement he broke me off no one gave me
the stimmies you get to keep that
we're shooting this on a stimulus check
[Laughter]
and patreon.com ah that's too funny um
all right this one's from timbo slice uh
do you or anyone in your family own a
shopping cart
[Laughter]
dude people walking down the street with
the shopping like a proper from a store
shopping cart is bad the ones that they
steal from like the coin operated ones
that's crazy yeah the fact that they had
to coin operate carts is do you
where do you shop will you food shop
when i was a child i well now it's like
in the west coast we have vons
and is that they coin vons is like uh
the equivalent to
i don't even know what's in new york
anymore as far as
stores go but fonz is like where they're
like well you know
chicken yoga pants it's not like you
know trader joe's or anything but it's
like the uh middle of the road okay it's
like a wegmans actually
is top notch yeah wegmans is top notch
but vons is like you know tops or
something i don't know
but then there's john's yikes there's
vons and there's giants
sound good but it's uh you know a lot
more ethnic food and it's i so there's a
john's and then there's avons but the
john's is closer to my house i go there
but in the east coast we were
a wegmans family and wegmans is great
yeah wiggins is fantastic but shopping
carts pretty classy for living on a
turnpike i'll tell you that yeah well
there was a bells much closer that we
would go to often but uh that became
quality markets and then that became
tops friendly markets kind of bowling
alley
[Laughter]
still a grocery so it's like an airplane
hangar but uh
shopping carts though is so wild i never
understood i get it like why a homeless
person would want one when you were a
kid you weren't here yeah as a kid
they're cool you're like oh i can that's
a [ __ ] race car you know what we did
one time as kids we stole the uh
scooters shopping carts really like the
motorized ones yeah yeah and we had a
slow getaway well yeah they didn't
notice
[Laughter]
we went down the street we went as far
as we could go till they stopped like
working sure and then we just ditched
them in like the woods that's good
that's a good that's like a rascal for a
joyride yeah yeah yeah it was fun they
didn't go very far very very fast but we
were like
then we took the hubcaps and the
headlights my mom also used to uh work
at a a fast food restaurant that had
patio furniture you know like for people
to eat on the patio sure
they decided to get rid of it yikes so
my mom took two of them sets and put
them in our backyard for patio furniture
that's bad what color were they oh they
were gross yeah i mean i don't even know
how to describe these but they were like
not even like sets they were
like uh a circular s stool seats
attached to like a table but they were
like made of they were all one piece oh
i know those things yes wow they're not
good no yeah they look
that's a bad thing yeah and my mom was
like we'll just take them for the
backyard as opposed to like you know a
regular table yeah it's like having one
of those chest sets they have in parks
in your backyard yeah it's like a
formica picnic table
did your parents smoke cigarettes no no
no i i started the only reason i started
smoking cigarettes really
is because i had this morning radio job
in cleveland that i hated
and i worked with this [ __ ] chuck
booms it was like a 80s comic
and he was so terrible and he just
haunted my day every day and i would
need to get out of these meetings and i
couldn't perpetually smoke weed so i
just started smoking cigarettes to get
outside
from this guy
and uh yeah here i am
and now we're here i started smoking at
25 that's how late wow that's old yeah
damn then i got a room with the ritz yep
that's right baby i feel like i uh i
stood to myself i'd quit at 35 but then
pandemic hits so yeah i gotta quit keep
it moving it's getting better we're
going to keep going everybody started
smoking during the pandemic
uh yeah i started back in the [ __ ]
pandemic like a [ __ ] well my 35th
birthday the one i claimed i would quit
on was during pandemic so i was like
[ __ ] that yeah you gotta see this thing
through you know what i mean
this could be the end of days i don't
want to go out like a [ __ ] i can't pull
out now
i might not even count it as my i might
be 34 still right now yeah yeah just put
that here's a watch that was a gimmick
yeah it's not getting chased by a zombie
with a piece of knickers
i want two chainsaws and a marlboro red
let's [ __ ] go
uh this one's funny this room uh angel
uh you ever changed the channel on your
tv with something other than a remote
uh i.e like a golf club like you were
too lazy to get up so you like poked it
or something i've used a golf club for
sure what golf club is a samford and son
no there's just one girl just like
[ __ ]
you mean like when there's no remote so
you gotta change it and you're standing
there like an idiot i'm too blind to
like have that coordination to go across
the room like that and touch it that way
but uh i've definitely just like
succumbed to whatever's on the tv if i
can't find it oh yeah
where you just go like well infomercials
it is i suppose that's what we say all
the time especially you know the road
now like hotels of like i'll watch
anything in a hotel room just like on a
proper cable of like anything
law and order mario lopez tells me about
the new movies [ __ ] three hours right
now that guy's working dude i can't turn
that [ __ ] off i'm just like all right
i'll hear about jungle cruise
[Laughter]
oh emily punching that
on the rock teaming up i just got the
hotel i'm in right now had a thing where
it was like use your phone to change the
channel i don't like those i don't like
i don't want to be linked up that's too
much it's got a giant qrc code on the tv
and you like scan it and then it's the
remote all of a sudden shows up on your
phone
that's how they watch you spanking it
later on that's fine let them watch it i
don't really there's dude i've succumbed
to give a little treat big brother is
watching it let him have it you know
here's all my porn i just recently lost
my here's a trash story i lost my debit
card recently and i had to do an only
fans audit because i found out how many
like through the you know rebill uh-huh
it lapsed so a bunch of my things were
like your subscription's up it was like
and i go i was subscribed to all those
really only fans was like my biggest
utility oh my god
when it's more than [ __ ] capable i
didn't even realize it and i go oh my
lord you're being that much i was
because of a pandemic i must have been
taking xanax's and subscribing to
[ __ ]
places by his own rules yeah i know what
you were doing i lost the i lost the uh
i was doing more scientific research
but i'm really glad i lost that debit
card because then i went through and i
was like which accounts do i need and
which do i not yeah you can't get rid of
all of them you know what i mean yeah
still gotta stay informed every day yeah
of course i paired it down to what i've
only been using that's crazy i'm not an
only fans guy oh i love it i but i do
feel like once i pull the trigger i've
never paid for porn and i think if the
one time i do pull the trigger i'm like
real girls you know in real life's porn
that makes sense that because i'm not
like doing like pro porn stars sites i'm
doing like oh i know this girl from
comedy uh not even not i don't do those
ones
but like a bartender or like a waitress
you know or like this girl from your
friend's friend or whatever those girls
that have only fans i'm like well [ __ ] i
guess i'll
sure yeah that's the tangible aspect of
it
do they know you oh yeah i'm i'm a big i
almost was like doing consulting i'm
like you're missing out on an
opportunity here
get yourself a ring light
it's like a podcast like you know how
they're like oh you guys got to get a
patreon for them i'm like you got to get
those pay-per-views going you got to get
those
you have your monthly sub but get the
pay-per-view content going you're
leaving money on the table they're
making a lot of money those gals there
are two women that i have like
encouraged to do only fans i just go if
you didn't only fans you'd make a
killing and they're like huh look at it
and then they started doing it and now
they're like thank you yeah it's so
crazy
i mean it's it's not even i i it doesn't
sound bad it's like a club burger or a
bud light and i want to run around i i
am like i'm like a only fan scout i'm
like
listen you got what it takes
my help and a lot of practice you could
be the best like john lovett's in a
league of their own
like you got the stuff tuts there's no
crying in only fans
hello
oh man
carla hooch oh god
league of their own classic film by the
way if that comes on in a hotel oh i'm
not i'm cancelling the show
i ain't [ __ ] leaving that dotty was a
piece oh dude dotty had it going on i
like kit too i mean i didn't like i
loved her all throughout the 80s and 90s
she was great all the girls in that
movie i mean uh i think rosie too could
get it who is uh who's the dude uh
marshall gary gary marshall of course
wasn't he [ __ ] betty spaghetti or is
that his daughter
betty spaghetti in that movie is someone
carl reiner's daughter maybe i don't
know i don't know that would all make
sense yeah yeah yeah yeah they all they
all operate something
yeah
was he [ __ ] penny or was it his
daughter
also he dropped daddy he dropped betty
spaghetti like it was oh yeah i got a
ball up there
rattling around got all their cards yeah
i'm on betty spaghetti's only fan
[Laughter]
betty spaghetti i went for it and toby
was point he's like that's it someone
get it
you see the new filter that was all me i
told her
[Laughter]
she's doing those pay-per-views now
spend the night with spaghetti they call
it it's crazy she [ __ ] the spaghetti
yeah
it's called italian night
ah that's too good oh [ __ ]
all right let's do a couple more here
and we gotta wrap it this has been a
[ __ ] heater baby i've been having a
great time shout out to tony south down
here um this one's funny i never thought
about it this is from jay do you still
raise your phone in the air to try to
catch a signal
and stuff
oh my god
[ __ ] that's so funny
who hasn't
i still i catch myself i'm like you
goddamn five g's what the [ __ ]
why it would go better up here you know
then i don't know
that's like you're calling it a [ __ ]
airstrike let's go
some other questions are so good
um
this one i feel you probably are
opinionated on this one's from grayson i
never had a question read yet how many
times will you pee in a toilet before
flushing also too i want to add
when do you flush in the in the in the
in the journey i'm uh you know i'm not a
yellow let it mellow guy you go down
i'll flush every [ __ ] yeah i don't even
ever i'll like spit in the toilet and
flush i'll flush all day long i don't go
i don't know what's up and then when do
you flush if you're paying at the toilet
do you wait until you're completely done
zip back up and flush because i'll go
like midway through i'll hit the flush
what i feel like they kind of race it a
little bit ah when you perfectly time it
it's incredible it's like yeah it's like
coming it's like coming at the four
seasons i don't like it's like it's like
playing slot machines
because then you leave some yellow in
there and you're
i know then you flush again [ __ ] this
environment hold on if it's an
old-school toilet you got to stand on
like a jerk off well yeah that's like
wait till it goes back up right you just
walk out and blame it on the
cat or something that's a tough look i
don't like leaving yellow in there
you know i will pee all over the floor i
forget where was i'm sorry
oh it was a green room uh i was in
recently and a guy pissed and
i went in after him and there was piss
in the toilet i'm like this [ __ ]
animal doesn't flush in the green one
uh-huh it was why yeah green room that's
a bar if you're drinking you're drunk
it's like it's chaos
that's what i'm saying that's what they
have at shoni's i go in there
we have to get we have to go to ashoni's
now you've got to that's i can't believe
you haven't i think there's still one
off 95. they're in north carolina all
over the place there's still one
like a shonies
look at bob evans too i'm not gonna lie
bob evans down on the farm not too bad
yeah
um all right let's see this one's from
neil first time patron uh have you ever
been blacklisted from a local pizza
place because you got dru you drunk
ordered and passed out before it arrived
too many times uh there was a store
called zoning knew he was gonna have so
i knew this was gonna hit oh this one's
big for me
i'm sorry man i knew it was gonna hit
dude just send it over now still pay for
it there was a uh
it wasn't a pizza place but it was a
calzone place it was
it was called zoni's and you could get
all these different calzones and they
would deliver until 5am
and i would pass out
all that might wake up 27 minutes
oh yeah but there was one time that i
went uh down to get it from the door
and i had one of those doors where like
the fire door closes behind you and then
you're like you're stuck outside of your
apartment yeah i lived on the third
floor and i was wasted and instead of
just like a normal person just buzzing
all the
the building units to get back in
i managed to go up the gutters and scale
holy my building and jump into the
third story window and i almost died and
i swear to god there was like i called
my room and after i go i just scaled the
building i'm [ __ ] spider-man and then
i like went back downstairs and got my
zone off the porch oh my god it was the
best feeling of my life the hell is a
cow yeah right
and those things were horseshit i'm sure
dude there's there's nothing trashier
than a place that just sells calzones
yeah that's something that you get at a
pizza place what's hilarious i feel like
it was a mafia front because they had
like changed their names
a couple of times but they just kept
taking different parts of the word
calzone so it would be like cows
now they're zonies and you're like wait
a minute what's going on yeah yeah yeah
then they're like houses
[Laughter]
also over here yeah over at knees we
make the best calzones
[Laughter]
i'll never forget scaling that building
because it was like it was just going up
on the ledges of the uh
so did they cut you off
uh they never cut me off but i was known
yeah
i was a known guy we did it one time in
north carolina with the
stripper we ordered a shrimp we got back
from the bar like let's get a stripper i
mean like it was like three or four
buddies she's just outside yeah she was
dude she was cold so bad dude banging on
the door we were [ __ ] we were drinking
rumple mints all night so there was no
way we were waking up she's banging on
the door and you leaving voicemails you
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] you owe me money
we walked down we're like oh like you
wake up we're like oh whatever that was
funny and then like they're in the lobby
they're like hey did you order like a
delivery last night we're like oh [ __ ]
they hate it i got the place i just
recently had the thing happen where
i ordered i've been i uh
twice now in the last month i ordered
from 7-eleven on post mates you know
quit bragging one of those oh getting
snacks and [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
and uh i had a slurpee yeah i had the i
had one night i fell asleep so i missed
it
the next time i did it the guy they
leave it or they well the next time i do
it the guy comes and he goes
hey i had you last week uh you never
came i left it right here did you get it
[ __ ] and i go
yeah i did i never got it
but i lied to him and said i did you
know he was probably lying to you he
knew you were lying well the fact that
he left it well the fact that i had the
same guy twice freaks me out yeah from
7-eleven from postmates yeah in general
just like the same guy that's weird i
don't like getting [ __ ] together i'm not
i gotta stop post-mating yeah josh good
to see you buddy yeah maybe take a walk
to the store instead of uh postmates
style yeah i can't have
running out of postmates drivers
yeah that's just giving you rides places
they just know they're just yelling into
my window as i'm
passed out josh it's me yeah
josh it's me randy did this do this
again you scumbag
josh you're tearing us apart i'm gonna
give you a one-star rating josh next
time i swear
um all right let's do one more this
one's just [ __ ] funny this is from
throbbing williams i don't know if
that's his government name
ever been chased more than once by the
same dog
you're doing something wrong
if you're getting chased by that by dogs
multiple times i feel like that's like
an old-timey neighborhood story you know
like the neighborhood dog that chases
you yeah i would always be the kid that
would be like oh the doggy and then it
would be like all right
[Laughter]
i'd be getting bit by the dogs
have you ever been responsible for a dog
being put down is the true
yeah that would suck that would suck so
but you know there's always that story
where it's like oh the dog bit the
neighbor kid and now we gotta kill it
yeah yeah yeah yeah great story to end
on
do you ever maim a child
you return to state's evidence against a
golden retriever
oh god funny josh thank you so much this
was so much fun hey guys thank you for
having me making my trip down here
worthwhile for cody's time share baby
we're having a lot of yeah dude what do
you got coming up you want the folks out
there to know uh i'm gonna be at buffalo
helium uh for
thanksgiving weekend actually if this
comes out in time for five shows and uh
next year we got bunch of gigs 2022
lined up uh but the josh potter show
comes out every tuesday go check out the
josh potter show on youtube and uh there
you'll find all my tour dates as well
and everything so fantastic what do you
got for them uh at cameron commodore
social media uh we'll be in upstate new
york we're going to be in albany
syracuse i'm also being hard first oh
yeah middle of december get tickets for
that uh and then yeah 2022 we're going
to be [ __ ] lock loaded headed
everywhere baby rocking and rolling gang
we love you we'll see you guys next week
peace